saint denis avec sa cathédrale son hôtel
de ville construit au début du siècle
ses rues piétonnes où fourmillent les
riverains et pluie mtm 93 les rebelles
mtm c'est le discours d'une génération
c'est le franc parler de leur vie de
tous les jours il positionne pour
personnes âgées des vides puisque je te
raconte le vécu
ntn c'est une bande de garçons et de
filles pardon de lady qui ont voulu
profiter de leur goût et leur don pour
la musique pour faire passer un message
looké comme les vrais rappeurs
d'outre-atlantique ils se produisent
déjà sur de nombreuses scènes où il
offre les chansons de leur premier album
ça arrive pas à tous les jeunes qu'on
l'a précipité de parler et qu'on puisse
capter le truc moi ce que je veux dire
donc on en balance quand on nous agite
un quart
vim
merrill offrant le look et la couleur
c'est pour eux très important voyez
l'analyse de joey sur les graffitis
entendait les tags
je suis dans windows avant de faire
avant de rap et je faisais des tags
il faut que la capitale soit mois sacré
parce que c'est que de la couleur je
retiens c'est dommage tout ce qu'on
assimile avec des tags c'est juste de la
couleur passe pas c'est pas une
dégradation
et oui c'est même dollars parfois
lorsque l'on y met de la bonne volonté
larissa pousse partout à beverly hills
comme à saint denis la zone ce n'est pas
un handicap
c'est pas un problème quoi si tu veux
vraiment faire quelque chose mais on a
choisi ce domaine bien d'autres dans
d'autres domaines ils peuvent excéder
pareils quoi tient ce que je veux dire
c'est ça qu'on veut démontrer le premier
truc droit message reçu trois sur trois
ntm ça décoiffe
à voir absolument s'il passe près de
chez vous
je ne sais pas
une claque
tu vois tu vois